[Music]
all right it is you boy MJ's a boss also
known as a Lord MJ back it again with
another review for the on Lords podcast
today I'm going to be reviewing
intruders hide and seek this game is
developed by Tesoro studios and I'd like
to thank them and the iron Lords podcast
for sending me the code Cognito addict
all them for supplying me I very much
appreciate it
this game is on the PlayStation VR and
the ps4 so if you want to play this game
just on the ps4 without the VR headset
you can or you can play it with the
headset you don't make the experience a
lot scarier so my thoughts about this
game I thought it was pretty good it's a
survival horror it's pretty creepy I
kind of wish that there was a more blood
in it because a the main story of the
game is that you're moving to a new
house with your sister and you and your
sister go exploring to see what your
dad's act - since he's acting weird and
want to go downstairs you see that
there's a lab and then after that your
dad leaves and goes upstairs and then
your parents end up getting kidnapped
and there's people inside of your house
trying to find you so you have to hide
well trying to find your family at the
same time so I thought this game was
pretty creepy like once the people grab
you
there's cursing and everything in it so
I just thought that there'd be more
violence in the blood except there
wasn't so I mean if there was one thing
to improve on I think that would be that
also thank you again to test Row Studios
for sending me this code I very much
appreciate it and if you guys are new to
the iron Lords podcast youtube channel
we are alive every Sunday with a new
person from the gaming industry with the
iron ores podcast you can pretty much
learn everything about gaming what is
coming out in the future stuff like that
I think it's a great idea and everything
a boss also known as Lord MJ thank you
guys for watching very much appreciate
it and peace
actually pretty creepy
[Music]